uh how can geometry in ancient times or
today be used to understand
reality and maybe how do you think about
geometry as a distinct
tool in mathematics and physics yes
geometry is my favorite part of math as
well
and greeks were enamored by geometry
they tried to describe
physical reality using geometry and
principles of geometry and symmetry
platonic solids the five solids they had
discovered had
these beautiful solids they thought it
must be good for some reality
there must be explaining something they
attached you know
one to air one to fire and so forth they
try to give
physical reality to symmetric objects
these symmetric objects are symmetries
of rotation
and discrete symmetry groups we call
today of rotation group in three
dimensions
now we know now we kind of laugh at the
way they were trying to connect that
symmetry to you know the laws of the
the realities of of physics but actually
it turns out
in modern days we use symmetries in not
too far away
exactly in these kind of thoughts
processes in the following way
in the co in the context of string
theory which is this
the field i study we have these extra
dimensions
and these extra dimensions are compact
tiny spaces typically but they have
different shapes and sizes we have
learned that if you if these extra
shapes and sizes have symmetries which
are
related to the same rotation symmetries
that the greek we're talking about
if they enjoy those discrete symmetries
and if you
if you take that symmetry and quotient
the space by it in other words identify
points under these symmetries
you get properties of that space at the
singular points
which force emanates from them what
forces
forces like the ones we have seen in
nature today like electric forces
like strong forces like weak forces so
these same principles
that was were driving them to connect
geometry and symmetries
to nature is driving
physics now much more you know modern
ideas but nevertheless the symmetries
connecting
geometry to physics in fact often we
sometimes we have we ask the following
question suppose i want to get this
particular
you know physical reality i want to have
these particles with these forces and so
on what do i do
it turns out that you can geometrically
design the space
to give you that you say oh i put the
sphere here i would do this i'll shrink
them
so if you have two spheres touching each
other and shrinking through
to zero size that gives you strong
forces
if you have one of them it gives you the
weak forces if you have this you get
that and if you want to unify forces do
the other thing
so these geometrical translation of
physics
is one of my favorite things that we
have discovered in modern physics in the
context of strength theory
you